Paterson is directed by Jim Jarmusch and
stars Adam driver as a bus driver that
makes sense this is an ordinary man who
lives an ordinary life he goes about his
business the film is very routine it
shows every day of the week it shows him
wake up with his beautiful wife they
have breakfast they talk he goes to work
and he writes some poetry down in his
notebook because he's also an aspiring
poet so the film is very much so about
the everyday man and what he might go
through in his life and there's really
nothing else to it it's completely free
of any real drama there's no big action
scene there's not a bomb on his bus if
he goes under fifty miles an hour this
film is just about an everyday guy who
goes to work he writes poetry he has a
great relationship with his wife he has
a not-so-great relationship with his dog
he goes to the bar every night and talks
to the bartender and he does the same
thing the very next day and that's it
Paterson is a film that celebrates the
ordinary the mundane and while some will
likely see this film and say nothing
happened
worst movie I ever saw I was
consistently enthralled by this film
that sticks up for the ordinary guy the
guy who works on a bus the guy who hangs
out at the bar the guy who sits at a
park and writes poetry the woman who
wants to stay home and bake cupcakes and
learn how to play guitar this film is
all about that and I can't tell you how
refreshing that was this film is such a
deterrent from everything else that
we're used to seeing in films it's just
a film about a guy who goes to work and
writes poetry and he talks to people and
they have very real and hilariously
funny conversations and that's something
about Patterson that really surprised me
was how real everything felt because
yeah it's a story about everyday
ordinary people but you're almost
waiting for something to happen you're
waiting for somebody to just come out
and say here's what the movies actually
about oh it really is just about this
guy who just has a normal life and it
really is very hilarious there are so
many observations about couples about
work about friends and people who you
might see at a bar that Jarmusch makes
and it's just so refreshingly real and
funny this is
subtly hilarious movie that older
audience members especially those
married or with significant others will
find great humor in its untraditional
narrative was also super refreshing as
someone who's used to seeing like
everything being a certain way in
Hollywood movies and I kept waiting for
the film to get boring like there was
going to be a scene where I was like oh
my god he's going to work again but it
never got boring I was always really
interested and what he was going to
write because the film shows his poetry
you see the text appear on the screen
and you get to listen to what he's
thinking in his head because he keeps it
very hidden from other people he doesn't
want even his wife really he doesn't
share it too much with her because he's
reclusive about it but there's an
amazing scene no spoilers with a guy on
a bench that just changed the whole
movie for me I love this film I loved it
from beginning to end it's so funny it's
so relatable and it's so refreshing and
I got to say Adam driver Wow
I am so glad that this actor is working
in movies today because this is my
favorite performance I've ever seen from
him he's so relentlessly charming in
this movie you just want to kind of
crawl into the screen and just be like
you're great man you're great now part
of me definitely related to this movie
more than I think most would because
both of my parents were bus drivers for
a very long time
and then eventually I also went to that
field and I worked on buses school buses
and I was like a an aid for handicapped
kids as I've said before so I know about
bus life and it was really well captured
in this movie and one specific scene
where his bus breaks down I was like
yeah I've been there before that sucks
the film might suffer and the replay
value category just due to its pacing
but that's the one minor flaw I could
find in this gem it's one of my favorite
movies of the year Adam driver is
amazing in it
I loved all the performances I loved how
real it all felt I loved that it was
just a movie about a normal guy who went
about his everyday life and it's also
really funny I'm gonna give Patterson an
A
if you guys think this movie is up your
alley definitely check it out just
beware that nothing really happens it's
such a strange movie and I appreciated
it for that imagine then pitching this
film to a studio so this movies about a
bus driver who writes poetry what
happens is you know they're bombers or
explosions is really like these going to
be action sequences there are going to
be boobs no that's it's really just
about an ordinary guy where's the
vampires where's the superheroes what
are you thinking sorry I'll make a comic
movie
guys thank you very much for watching I
want to make sure you guys know that my
promotion with Squarespace is still
going on if you go to squarespace.com
slash chris Duckman and use the coupon
code stuff then you can get 10% off your
first purchase this is a fantastic tool
for web design and since i started in
web design peckin the day going to the
library making my own website this was a
good fit for me
Squarespace is a fantastic tool for web
design they have 24/7 customer support
beautifully designed templates are very
easy to use system and if you sign up
for a year you get a free domain name
for that year which is easily the best
part of all this so please go to
Squarespace comm slash Chris Duckman and
use that coupon code stuckman for 10%
off you guys are the best definitely
check out Patterson I think you'll
probably enjoy it if you like movies
that are really about nothing thanks
very much guys for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes